In Insidious One, I pointed out ghosts that were hiding in the background of scenes,
and the second movie would contain an even more, well hidden, spirit.
There's a scene where Renai is on the phone, and as she walks past, you can
see the woman in white sitting in the living room.
But once she reaches the doorframe, the apparition is gone.
Director James Wan and screenwriter Leigh Whannell explained why they do this on
Insidious Chapter Two's Blu ray.
The idea is if one audience member catches it and reacts, then their friends
will go, what? What did you see? And the tension in the movie theater builds.
Personally, outside of theater experience, I always find it creepy
to go back and discover something that's not supposed to be there.
So in this video, I'll be going over all of the things you might have missed
in Insidious Chapter Two. To learn about the artifacts in Elise's basement
and more Insidious secrets.
Stick around to the end of this video.
🎵Metal Music🎵
This baby stroller looks like Pac-Man, and I'm tired of not talking about it.
Welcome to Things You Missed, James Wan, Leigh Whannell, and just about everyone
from the first Insidious came back for the sequel.
For Wan, it was his first time directing a sequel.
Whannell had experience with sequels, having penned the 2nd and 3rd Saw movies
and even a miniseries called Insidious Spectral Sightings about
Specs and Tucker's paranormal adventures before meeting Elise.
If you haven't seen it, don't worry too much.
It's pretty boring and was rendered non canon by the events of
Insidious Chapter Three.
Chapter Two, unfortunately, isn't my favorite either.
I knew something was weird with this one when I heard the younger version of
Elise dubbed over with the voice of the 70 year old Lin Shaye.
-[Elise] See things, things no living person is supposed to see.
There's actually a UK version of the trailer that includes the original
lines from the younger Elise.
-[Elise] He sees things. No living person is supposed to see.
I wish they just stuck with that in the movie.
I think the audience is smart enough to understand who Elise is and
understand that people's voices can change over time, except Rivers Cuomo.
Despite that, the expanded characterization for Elise is appreciated.
We get to see her house for the first time, which happens to be the perfect
place to jump into some more Things You Missed.
🎵Slice🎵
🎵Mysterious Music🎵
In my episode on the first movie, I talked about the red door, which
connected the Lambert's house in the Further to the layer of the demon.
We see another red door marking the main antagonist here in Chapter Two.
So it makes sense that when we enter the home of the franchise's
Ghost Whisperer, Elise, we must enter through these big red gates.
She used to do her psychic readings at home, so the red entryways are
probably meant to be inviting to spirits on the other side.
Now that we've seen a couple examples of the color red representing the
gateway between the living and the dead, I'm reminded of another movie that
used the color in the same way, The Sixth Sense, which had red doorknobs,
red flowers, red tents, and more to show the connection between our world
and the world of the dead.
Elise's basement, where she does her readings, is also covered in red,
Just like the demonic layer in Insidious.
The basement is decked out with paraphernalia artifacts, which serve as
this franchise's version of the artifact room from the Conjuring, which had
come out just two months earlier.
Elise may have died at the end of the first movie, but her presence is still felt,
and she seems to leave a message for Specs and Tucker.
They find an old tape and put it into her Panasonic VHS player, but several
letters on the logo are crossed out, causing it to read Panic.
After possessing Josh Lambert's body, the Bride in Black tried to convince
Renai that everything was fine and that she should not panic.
So this was Elise's way of saying, don't listen to him panic.
The reading room also contains a mannequin wearing a gas mask.
A callback to the gas mask seance that Elise performed in the first movie.
The second film introduces a new psychic character, Carl, who has his own
unique way of contacting the dead using these Ouija dice.
Another common element this one shares with Insidious is the cinematography.
In the previous episode, I pointed out how the camera was always moving
through doorframes and looking through doorframes in the real world to
highlight the bright openness of the real world, in contrast to the dark,
closed off nature of the Further.
We see more of that in Chapter Two, as well as more evidence that the doors
are used to link these two worlds.
For example, Carl gets a vision of the antagonist Parker Crane when he
touches a doorframe at the abandoned hospital and at Parker's home,
When they discover they are speaking to an evil entity, all of the doors in
the house slam shut.
There are a couple more connections to the first Insidious.
While Specs and Tucker are watching the tape from Josh's childhood recorded
in 1986, Lorraine is at home and the movie Carnival of Souls is playing on
her TV.
It reminds me of something that I discovered when making a video on the
Red Faced Demon from the first Insidious.
James Wan referred to the character as something out of a crazy mystical carnival.
It sounds a lot like John, a creepy character from Carnival of Souls
who even has a similar hairstyle to Red Face.
The next morning, when we see the mom, Renai, wake up, the scene looks just
like the introductory scene in the first movie, only this time Josh cannot
be seen sleeping there beside her.
Our first clue that something isn't right.
Those who saw my episode on the first movie may remember that Leigh Whannell
wanted to avoid any false jump scares.
If they were going to release the tension, he wanted it to be a real threat.
That's not the case in Insidious Chapter Two.
Early on, Renai trips on this baby saucer for a cheesy scare.
However, there is some significance to this scene.
The saucer plays the song Row, Row, Row Your Boat, the same song that the
new villain, the Woman in White, can be heard singing in the living room
shortly before abducting the baby.
This demonstrates how music can be perceived in both the Further and the
real world, which sets up the moment when we discover that Josh had been
trying to get through to Renai by playing her song on the piano when he was
trapped in the Further.
There are a few more instances of foreshadowing.
Dalton can be seen reading Turn of the Screw before bed.
This is an 1898 horror novel.
Maybe you're familiar with the 2020 adaptation The Turning, or the much
better 1961 adaptation The Innocence.
Dalton is only nine or ten years old, so he has no business being interested
in this book.
However, considering his ability to see things like Elise, it's possible
that his clairvoyant ability caused him to choose this book.
Because when Carl, Lorraine, Specs and Tucker later investigate the old
crane house, the Woman in White unscrews the chandelier, which nearly
crashes down on Carl and Lorraine.
Then again, he also seems to read Moby Dick, so maybe he just loves reading
old classics.
There may also be a moment of foreshadowing when Specs and Tucker face off
in their own version of Rock, Paper, Scissors.
-[Tucker] This better be the goddamn ninja.
-[Specs] Superior sense of smell, my friend.
After arriving at the old Crane house, Specs is the first one to comment on the smell
-[Specs] What is that smell?
Which eventually leads them to discovering the bodies of Parker Crane's victims.
One more small detail about Specs and Tucker, their van's license plate says
AstralP, short for Astral Projection, the ability shared by Elise, Josh,
Dalton and Lorraine, which allows them to leave their physical bodies to
explore the spiritual world of the Further.
I saw it with haunted, and it's not a friend, it's a parasite.
I've never felt such a malignant presence.
I'm guessing James Wan really likes that word, malignant.
He would eventually make a whole movie about it in 2021.
At the time, though, it wasn't exactly a James Wan Easter egg.
But that's not to say that this movie isn't brimming with them.
Along with even more things you missed.
🎵Haunting Music🎵
The first, Insidious, ends with The Bride and Black strangling,
Elise, so at the beginning of the second one, there's an investigation
during which Renai is interrogated by Steve Harvey.
Her guest badge for the police station simply says Metropolitan Police, just
like the police stations in James Wan's Saw franchise, which never seemed to
specify a city.
However, we do later see a newspaper that clues us in on where Insidious
takes place.
We've always known they live in California, but more specifically, it seems
to be Newark, California.
After discovering the VHS tape from Josh's childhood visit from Elise,
Tucker digitizes the footage to view on his laptop.
If you pause right before he pulls up the footage, you can get a glimpse at
his desktop background, which is a picture of the ghost hunting duo posing
with James Wan.
There are also a bunch of Adobe Premiere files, a Photoshop file of
something from the hospital, which they haven't been to yet in the movie,
and a movie file for the videotape.
For the film shoot of Insidious Two, this was clearly the media laptop,
something the art director could plug in anytime they needed to show
something on a screen.
You can tell because these files were all modified in 2013, yet the movie
takes place in 2010.
We weren't supposed to see this stuff, which is why it's only on screen for
a fraction of a second.
However, you could make the argument that the reason that they have a bunch
of video and photo editing software is for their miniseries Spectral Sightings,
the non Canon web series I mentioned earlier.
In Insidious Chapter Three, we learned that before meeting Elise, they fake
their show through fancy video editing.
-[Tucker] Thanks little man.
-[Tucker] Did some of my best editing on that one.
-[Specs] Definitely some of our best editing.
As for the date modified, maybe Tucker accidentally set his laptop's date
and time incorrectly.
I wouldn't put it past him.
Insidious Two features even more of the usual James Wan tropes that we've
grown to expect.
He loves to include mannequins in his work, and there are two in this movie,
in Elisa's reading room and in Parker Crane's old house.
We also know that James Wan loves creepy dolls.
When we first see the child version of Parker Crane in the Further his room is
filled with girl dolls, which we come to learn is because his evil mother is
forcing him to act like a girl against his will to get revenge on the father.
When we first see the young Parker from behind, he looks a whole lot
like Annabelle, who had made her debut appearance in The Conjuring earlier
that summer.
Since Carl has the ability to see into the past of objects that he touches,
he's able to touch Parker's veil and see his transformation into The Bride
in Black, where we also see the bride's weapon of choice, a saw.
However, I don't know if this was an intentional reference.
If it was, he might have used a hacksaw more akin to the ones that Adam and
Dr. Gordon were left with in James Wan's breakout movie.
There is a weapon that Wan loves to use even more than a saw, and that would
be his trusty tranquilizer needle.
Jigsaw uses it in saw and its many sequels, and it's also used in Malignant.
In pretty much every movie it's used in,
It knocks the victims unconscious almost immediately, yet seems to be
completely safe for the person being tranquilized.
According to this video from Life Noggin, that only works in the movies.
In any event, seeing as how Insidious Chapter Two is a movie, our
protagonists try to use a tranquilizer to knock out the possessed
Josh Lambert, but it backfires and ends up going into Tucker.
Tucker is a lot bigger than Josh, which could explain why it doesn't put him
to sleep for very long.
As you may know, James Wan and Leigh Whannell both come from Australia, as
well as cast members Rose Byrne and Angus Sampson.
For this reason, during the scenes in Josh's old room, you can spot an
Australian flag hanging on the wall.
They also rode kangaroos to set every single day of production, all four of them.
The flag certainly serves as sort of a crew reference Easter egg, and
you can find more in the scene where the protagonist hunt down Parker
Crane's medical file in the abandoned hospital.
His physician is listed as T. Spence,
which stands for Thomas Spence, Insidious Two's prop master.
One of the articles, hidden away in a chest in Parker's old house, is also
written by Thomas Spence.
Parker's dentist is listed as Jay Garner, which stands for Jason Garner, the
movie's art director.
And there's another article written by Hilary Parker, an Art department
production assistant.
As I mentioned, I'm a much bigger fan of the first Insidious than the second.
Some people fault the first movie for being too derivative, but even
if it is kind of a reskin of Poltergeist, it's at least a good reskin of Poltergeist.
It's scary, it's weird, and it has lovable characters.
Insidious would truly continue to follow in the footsteps of the Poltergeist
franchise because Chapter Two takes after Poltergeist Two.
Both families temporarily move in with the grandmother, but the haunts
follow them and continue to terrorize them.
Both introduce a new ghostly antagonist who motivates the ghost to try to
harm the family.
There's even a scene where Steven, the dad in Poltergeist, swallows this
supernatural parasite thing, which causes him to become possessed and attack
his wife.
It's very similar to the end of Insidious Chapter Two, where they confirm
that Josh is possessed and he tries to kill Renai.
However, the possession scene is a pretty short section of Poltergeist Two.
The finale of Insidious Two takes most of its inspiration from another movie
that is much more well known.
It feels like a really bad redux of The Shining, and if you watch my
channel, you know that I'm a huge fan of The Shining, so I won't stand for that.
Once it comes out that the other characters know that Parker Crane has
possessed Josh's body, he goes crazy and tries to kill them.
It feels very much like he's trying to act like Jack Torrance.
He's wearing this plaid bathrobe that makes me think of the plaid shirt that
Jack wore during his rampage.
He may be trying to act like the real Josh, whose spirit is also wearing
plaid in the Further, but it just makes me think of Jack Torrance.
He snoops on Carl the same way that Jack Torrence snoops on his wife.
-[Jack] What you got there? How do you like it?
His fake smile is clearly inspired by Jack Nicholson's faux friendliness.
After losing his mind, even the way he mockingly enunciates his words seems
copy pasted from Nicholson's performance.
-[Josh] What have you got behind your back? Why don't you ask your dice what I have behind my back?
-[Wendy] Maybe he should be taken to a doctor.
-[Jack] You think maybe he should be taken to a doctor?
He has a hand injury. He becomes woozy after getting hit with a baseball bat.
He tries to bash a door down to reach and harm his family.
In Insidious, it's with a fire extinguisher, and in The Shining, it's with a
fire axe.
-[Jack] Here's Johnny.
At least he didn't say, here's Joshy or something, I guess.
I like Patrick Wilson, but it's his subtlety that makes him good.
Asking him to replicate one of the great madman performances of all time is
like asking the other Patrick Wilson to play lead guitar in Weezer.
That's a bad example, because Pat is actually pretty good on
guitar. They both are.
And they can both play the drums.
But my point is, the actor Patrick Wilson is suited to play Josh Lambert and
Ed Warren, not this.
-[Josh] Shut up.
-[Josh] Get out of my head.
-[Josh] Get out of here.
Sorry, I didn't mean to turn this into a movie review, but I've just been
wanting to say that for a while.
Much like how I would like to forget Insidious Chapter Two.
Carl helps hypnotize Josh and Dalton so they can forget about their
abilities to astral project, which, if you ask me, is completely idiotic.
Did they not learn their damn lesson the first time? What's going to happen
when Dalton has a kid and he has the ability to astral project?
You're better off remembering the past so that you can try not to repeat it.
The final, final scene shows Specs and Tucker on their next job and the
ghost version of Elise joining them from the Further.
She hears the crackling sound made by the Red Face Demon in a new house and
looks up and sees something shocking.
The movie ends on a cliffhanger, which I'm fine with, but then Blumhouse
pulls the same BS they did with The Purge Election Year and
makes two prequels before addressing that cliffhanger.
However, in the case of Insidious, one of those prequels is the best film in
the entire franchise, and I'm covering it next on Things You Missed.
Check out that video on the left.
And remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every week.
Ring the death bell and select all notifications, and I will see you in the
next one, assuming we both survive.